actually not my job to answer your
questions I've asked you two questions
should a mass stay in power and are they
a terror group you're refusing to answer
either of them that is very telling talk
TV is the only place where you get the
truth you've done a book on poetry
poetry and music for the many I love
poetry we can agree on
that on TV on radio Radio and on your
smartphone this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on pan s that a schizophrenic
triple murderer who led a knife Rampage
through a British City avoids jail on
the grounds of diminished responsibility
does he belong Behind Bars and could his
blood bath have been
prevented President Biden says the
United States will respond as an Iran
back militia kills three US soldiers in
Jordan Trump says we're heading for
World War II is the war in in Gaza
spiraling out of
control and controversial transgender
swimmer Leah Thomas sued to regain her
place in Elite competition including the
Olympics I'll talk to one of her former
[Music]
teammates live from the news building in
London this is Piers Morgan uncensored
good evening from London welcome to PE
Morgan uncensored valdo cakan is a
triple murderer who Massac three
innocent people in a knife Rampage then
sped across the city of nding him in a
stolen van and rammed into three more
people his victims were Barnaby Weber
and graer Malik Kumar two students aged
just 19 and Ian coats a 65y old carer
just a month or two from retirement
before stealing his white van to
continue the bloodthirsty spree the
judge was told in evidence that valdo
cakan is a paranoid schizophrenic but
also that he's an highly intelligent man
with a degree in mechanical engineering
two consultant psychiatrist submitted
evidence that he knew what he was doing
and was not insane at the time of his
Rampage where cak's been found not
guilty of murder accepting free charges
of manslaughter by admin responsibility
instead of going to jail he'll now go to
a mental hospital for an indeterminate
amount of time reportedly but allowed to
pass his time building Lego sets playing
the guitar learning how to paint in a
room not a cell decorated with plants
and rugs it's hard to agree with the
family of Ian coats who says calican has
got away with murder the NHS mental
health trusts have to be held
accountable for their failures along
with the police all we can do is hope
that in due course some sort of Justice
will be served this man has made a
mockery of the system and he has got
away with murder yeah he has make no
mistake calican is a monster chilling
footage charts his demented spree as he
pounces on his two teenage victims who
were chatting happily together as they
walked home from a night out and after
then stabbing Ian Coast to death he
stole his van rammed into three
pedestrians two of whom suffered
life-changing injuries can only imagine
how many more people he might have
killed if police hadn't finally brought
the blood bath to an end and there were
serious questions to answer about
whether the police should have prevented
it from ever happening as far back as
May 2020 cakan was arrested for breaking
into two apartments forcing one
terrified resident to jump out of a
window to escape him he was assessed as
psychotic but after being discharged he
broke into another
then stopped taking his medication a
year later he traveled to MI5 in London
and told him to stop controlling him he
assaulted a police officer he attacked a
flat M he was kicked out of hsb's
University he attacked two colleagues at
a warehouse the list goes on and on and
on this looks like a total system
breakdown which allowed a cold blooded
Mass killer to Rampage through our
streets and the Bev loved ones of his
victims now have to bear the scars of a
complete absence of Justice well joining
me now as the lawyer right broadcaster
Chris D KC talk TV contributor Esther
kru and the associate editor of the
Daily Mirror Kevin
Maguire okay let's get into this Chris D
you're a KC uh explain to the British
public many of them are completely
baffled by this how this guy complete
guilty to attempted murder and be found
guilty as charged uh but then have his
murder charges downgraded to
manslaughter with diminished
responsibility
well it's very straightforward in law
although I have to say that it's not
been very well explained by the media or
or indeed uh possibly by the judicial
system but in law it's very
straightforward the defense of
diminished responsibility which
basically arises where someone is so
psychotic that their perception of
reality is completely distorted uh they
can plead guilty to admin responsibility
only to murder that defense is not
available to attempted murder as a
matter of Law and that's why the the
difference between the two charges you'd
have to ask Parliament it's a
parliamentary decision you're you're a
KC I mean do not share my utter
amusement at the fact that you complete
guilty in a situation like this to
attempted murder because you're
attempting to murder people but on the
charge of actually murdering people
you're allowed to get away with a a
lesser charge and a cushier sentence I
mean it just makes absolutely no sense I
can quite understand that these families
believe that the law is just not fit for
purpose
here well it's neither a lesser a lesser
s s nor a cushy sentence neither of
those things is true he's not in a
prison cell he won't spend any time in a
prison cell he's not in a prison cell
because he was psychotic what you didn't
say in your misleading introduction was
that all five psychiatrists including
the prosecution psychiatrist agreed that
he only committed these crimes because
of his paranoid schizophrenic psychosis
but for that all the psychiatrist and
the judge agreed he wouldn't have done
any of it so let's look at the way we're
thinking about and talking about mental
illness rather than as it were taking
someone who was so psychotic that he was
so Disturbed he took three lives and
treating them as if they were a pariah
for the sake of their mental heal I see
more mass murderers are psychos to be
perfectly honest with you otherwise they
wouldn't Comm they wouldn't commit Mass
Mur convicted of murder well I also
remember the yor shiper for examp
convicted of murder yor sharer was
convicted of murdering 13 people later
identifi was identified as as a paranoid
schizophrenic but he was found guilty of
13 murders indeed why that's correct at
the time of the tri he was undiagnosed
we were it was a very very long time ago
Psychiatry has moved on a lot in 40
years or so and nowadays psychiatrists
are able to accurately diagnose
schizophrenia and that's why all five
doctors agreed there was no doubt about
the medical diagnosis and there was no
doubt in the high court judge's mind
that these crimes derived entirely from
his mental state and not from any
underly History of Violence okay why did
two experts who were called disagree
then they didn't disagree that was was
another part of your misleading
introduction all five agreed it was
diminish responsibility none of them
suggested that he was insane now the
insanity laws date back to the 1840s and
that's an entirely and very specific
legal issue nobody was saying he was
responsible for his actions the
difference was is it insanity or is it
diminished responsibility they all
agreed it was diminished responsibility
and that's the significance of insanity
not to say that he was in some way
competent but because it was a in the
dividing line between insanity and
demmin responsibility the evidence was
clear but what I find baffling about
this is that he seems to have been so
calm chillingly calm in the way he's
planned all this getting all his weapons
nothing about his behavior that we've
seen really suggests he's having some
kind of psychotic episode from any of
the video footage this is a guy just
basically planning calmly to commit mass
murder and that again a lot of my
questions to you Chris are more
reflecting what the public are thinking
about this which is a lot of anger based
on the anger of the families is you know
I'm I'm I'm sort of more in the bemused
Camp to be honest with you um because he
doesn't look to me like someone who's
not completely in control now I accept
that maybe the experts say he was a
paranoid schizophrenic but everything
about the way he planned and executed
this looks to the you know
unprofessional eye admittedly that he is
just a coldblooded pre-planned
killer well if you read the judgment and
the judge set out in great detail he
quoted from all five of the psychiatrist
he went through the entire history of
this man going back to day one he was a
very clever man he' obviously gone to
University and studied engineering there
was there's no intellectual deficit the
difference here and the judge explained
this with real Clarity and compassion
was that his belief set which was
completely paranoid was created by
delusions from his illness he believed
that that he had to listen to a voice in
his head telling him to go and commit
these murders or his own family would be
killed he believed that to be his own
truth because of his psychosis and when
people understand that's what's in his
mind it perhaps makes more sense that
he's going to spend the rest of his life
in a psychiatric institution rather than
a prison which which are only intended
for People final question for you at the
moment Chris but will he spend the rest
of his life in a institution or is there
as I believe is a case the possibility
that he may actually get out and that
would not have applied if he'd been
given a forli sentence for
murder well that would have depended on
the sentence that the judge decided but
you're absolutely right had it not been
for his diminished responsibility he
would inevitably have been convicted of
of triple murder and he would have
received a whole life order and never
been released from prison that is true
but this particular order gives no
earliest state for release and he could
only ever be released if two things
happened one a mental health tribunal
decided that he was no longer a danger
to the public and two the Secretary of
State for justice agreed to his release
now if you just think about it for two
or three seconds the likelihood of any
such scenario is so remote as to be not
even worthy of belief okay uh Kevin ask
you've been waiting patiently here Kevin
what's what's your take I watched you
this morning on Good Morning Britain um
with two of the parents incredibly
powerful moving interview and you were
kind of wrestling I could see with your
heart saying one thing your head saying
another about this that's right I put my
uh yeah I put myself in the shoes of the
parents Barnaby's parents and I I would
feel cheated by by the system but I
think where it went wrong is not on the
sentence because he will be locked away
forever and I visited a secure mental
hospital before you have to go five six
checks just like you're going into a
prison I think it's why was he free
anyway when he'd been sectioned four
times and there were warrants out for
his arrest and the police hadn't picked
him up
I think that is the failure not the not
the verdict not the judge saying it is
manslaughter through diminish
responsibility okay but Esther I mean
when you hear that he when the public
hear that this guy's pleading guilty to
attempted murder but then is not found
guilty of the ones he murdered in my
estimation I think they're entitled to
be pretty amused by what the law has
done here and I think I mean Chris La is
door is completely correct here that is
the law yeah but the law seems to me to
be inexplicable I mean that's what I
really struggled with how can someone
who traveled from London proud the
streets of notingham for hours not have
be convicted of you know premeditating
this attack um but I listened to the the
the judges comments and then it was he
spent 33 minutes explaining it and he he
testified on behalf of the five um sort
of Psych psychiatrist that said this man
is suffering from paranoid schizophrenia
I think we also have to consider the
fact that he's a danger to prison inates
as well as prison wardens if he did go
go to prison I think the only Justice
any parent whose child has been murdered
would be for the person to be hung but
in this country we don't hang people for
having a mental illness and that's
that's the really difficult thing to to
take from this the fact that this person
is so mentally unwell that he'll have to
spend the rest of his life Behind Bars
imagine if he becomes cognizant of what
he's done he might even wish he was hung
because he couldn't live with himself he
murdered three people the difference of
course about being in one of these
institutions Kevin he will be mandated
to take all his medication they will
make sure he does which you know by all
we know about him when he took the
medication he was relatively normal
right yeah and there's a great failure
in so-called care in the community that
people are really basically left on
their own yeah and this guy was
obviously frightening obviously
terrifying to other people and obviously
a danger but the end result is he will
not be on the streets he will be
detained do we really think people with
severe mental illnesses should be put in
you know what even but I but I really am
with a
if the CPS had gone ahead with the
murder charge they would have lost and
then they would have to have a retrial
and put the parents through more years
of of the the slow clunky British
judicial system and I don't think that's
fair either Lucy letbe for instance you
know her the parents got a knock on the
door in 2018 that someone may have
murdered your baby and then it went to
trial in 2023 that's five years of Agony
imagine if you know that the trial
wasn't as meticulous as it was and they
had to go through another five years of
that Agony and I think they've actually
saved the parents uh I know it doesn't
seem that way but they've saved the
parents let bring let me bring uh Chris
back in here because the chairman of the
criminal Bar Association Tana akkin
Casey said the court the court backlogs
and a lack of barers me the reasons for
the different outcomes were not
explained to the families which seems to
me absolutely shocking shameful actually
that these poor families were completely
unaware that this was all going on
behind the scenes until right at the
last
minute well if that's the case of course
it's utterly um uh it's a complete
failure of the justice system um but the
point that was being made by Tanner
Atkins is a very good one the truth is
that the weights for justice are almost
indefinite and those who have been raped
are waiting on average four and a half
years to give evidence against their
attacker if they can make it that long
uh four and a half years is the average
peers a rape trial to get to trial after
the charge and that because the system
is as as T Atkins made clear there are
nowhere near enough specialist Powers as
you can imagine the skill and
sensitivity it takes to either defend or
prosecute in a rape case there are
simply nowhere near enough of them left
because the government starved the
system of funding for well over a decade
and and and many many people left the
profession and so victims pay the price
every single day in our system and sadly
in cases like this murder cases and
other cases whether it be rape or other
sorts of serious violent offenses um the
prosecutors simply don't have enough
time to sit for an hour or two or three
frankly if it in a council of perfection
peers in a case of this kind I would
have wanted to sit with the family for
an entire day and listen to every single
problem that they had with the decision
justify and explain it properly and that
didn't happen and that's a breakdown of
the system I mean Kevin on every level
these families have been let down by A
system that has just not been fit for
purpose here no it's it's callous and
it's cruel and there they are they're
just treated as Spectators while they've
lost a loved one they they should be
taken through every step and involved it
has to be explained maybe they'll object
at times you would understand that you
have just had your life totally changed
in the most gruesome and horrific way
but the the system is is broken it is
it's absolutely think about it if you
take your child to to a specialist and
say my child has depression they have to
wait over a year just to see someone so
if you think about the lack of Medical
Health Resources that we have in this
country it's no surprise that someone
like this too Chris just said about a
four and a half year average weight for
a rap case there's no justice and that
will explain why very few rape cases
ever result in a conviction because
people people give up they just spare
they don't want to bring the claim in
the first place let the you know the the
system is is Broad smash make it work it
works I I I I absolutely stand by Brit
the British judicial system I think when
it works it works it's just slow and
clunky and undefended and unfortunately
I think the the prosecution knew this
and they wanted to save the parents
years of Agony and you know what the
British public I can tell you uh they're
they're going to feel the same way the
families have felt yeah which is
Betrayed at every level the by the
system but also inexplicable that he can
be simultaneously convicted of
attempting murder but not of murder no
one's going to understand that I'm sure
that is the law I know it's the law
Chris has confirmed it's the law it's
just the laws an ass because if the
public can't understand something that
simple then it has to change I just
don't think anyone can hear that and go
what yeah it makes no sense and if I was
one of those parents I'd be I'd be
furious Mur murder is intentional
killing I mean Chris stall explain it's
it's intentionally going to kill
somebody manslaughters unintentionally
what's attened murder then well you
attempt to kill somebody but you don't
do it but if you you're deliberately
attempting to kill why isn't there a
case of Murder By You Know sort of I
mean I thought I thought you're mentally
ill as you do it look but traditionally
it would have been a murder case the
mitigating Factor would be his mental
health issu that's what most people
would let me ask Chris one final
question what is to stop Chris somebody
in a who who's just a killer playing the
the mental health card saying I'm a
paranoid schizophrenic I mean what's to
stop them doing
that well I'll I'll tell you what to
stop them there's two things firstly
both the prosecution and the defense get
expert reports from not one not two but
a total of five of the most senior
Forensic psychiatrists in the country
who deal with Psych otic patients 24
hours a day 7 days a week secondly
there's a high court judge who has to
make the overall decision he weighs all
of that evidence and he considered very
carefully whether there was a
possibility he explicitly referred to it
is it possible that he's as it were
swinging the lead or that somehow this
is fabricated and the judge said the ab
the possibility of that was so slim that
it was it was not even worthy of
consideration because of the expert
opinion from so many different places
but you do make a good point Pier which
is that you do need intent to kill to
commit a murder and so I can well
understand why people are confused
because actually the defense of
diminished responsibility should be
available to both makes absolutely no
sense to me and I'm sure not to many
people but uh Chris I appreciate you
joining me thank you very much to Kevin
Esther thank you very much and our
hearts go out to all those poor families
I can't think of anything worse in the
world than what they've had to endure uh
absolutely horrific and the fact the
system let them down so badly and the
fact they end up with not even a murder
conviction is to me completely wrong
anyway thank you I appreciate you're
joining me on S next Netanyahu says the
Hamas war is a war between Iran and the
West as three US soldiers are killed by
Iranian militants in Jordan Donald Trump
says we're on the brink of World War II
is he right Dennis Prager and J yuger
are up
[Music]
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well Tred most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn you know
what I love about sport today we do it
all sunak sella
scon a woman can become a man and a man
can become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably
insane slick Wishy seemed intelligent
forensic even a bit of a Statesman the
type of man you trust to look after your
house while you went on
holiday this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense happy birs night we slick it
Kur and timorous beasty panics
and K stas accused the government of
failing a generation after a record
number of young people were killed last
year using a knife or sharp object we
need to make sure that when we say we're
going to ban them we actually do ban
them there are so many politicians now
who just said my dad was a
boss you're David Cameron no he
wasn't was like brought to you by St KH
the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great mayor
sadique KH brilliant
guy in the cities there are areas where
there are no vegetables it's
particularly difficult for those people
to do what Mark is saying if he comes up
with this argument again I'll sit on him
stop creating all of these funny little
factions with their funny little names
the new conservatives the ERG the common
sense research group the red wool red
trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what what
is that if you're talking about
multiculturalism it's workingclass white
boys who get put in the Army the poorest
people in society are the ones who are
going to be put on the front line
something is going horribly wrong we can
do a lot better Donald Trump didn't just
win he obliterated this is a guy facing
nearly a 100 criminal charges and yet
all that's done is actually make him
more popular Trump is canny enough to
know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you or that's the wake up did my 6
months I came back nobody would touch me
I put my head down and persisted and
carried on when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are they a terror
group you're refusing to answer either
of them that is very telling talk TV is
the only place where you get the truth
you've done a book on poetry poetry and
music for the many I love poetry we can
agree on
that
well you told me last time something
happened that was so depraved you
couldn't even tell me on air there's
people still missing from my bachelor
bodyy right there we never
found well there's you money and then
there's Elon musku you literally says
you the government thought I was not
paying my fine that I had they thought I
was hiding money they looked at my
with a freaking microscope right
and you know what they found after 5
years
zero
look at Donald Trump he was a great
president has Margo Robbie thanked you
yet for you propelling her career she
did I thought Barbie suck have you seen
Leah CU you know what they can't make
movies like that because they just can't
they can't it was pretty wild do you
ever get urges to just go and take loads
of ques ques yeah you have one you know
we can go
after just for the record I do not have
any
gu
very entertaining interview with the
real life Wolf of Wall Street Jordan
bful that's tomorrow night uh well worth
an hour of your time he's highly
entertaining fascinating guy welcome
back to uncensored Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu talked tough
on Iran in a new interview telling
uncensored regular Douglas Murray that
Iran is bent on domination and Conquest
he framed Israel's ongoing war with
Hamas as a battle between the west and
Iran before warning that Israel will
fight on as long as it takes alone if
necessary come to President Biden warns
the US will respond after three American
soldiers were killed in a drone strike
by Iranian back militants on a US base
in Jordan Donald Trump meanwhile says
we're on the brink of World War III is
he right what you me to discuss all this
is the conservative talk show host and
author Dennis Prager and the Democratic
presidential Challenger Jen yuger
welcome to uh both of you Dennis Prager
um a lot of jungle drums beating now
about the potential of a massive
escalation in this war in the Middle
East uh because of these attacks uh
killing Americans because of Biden's
comments and because of Iran's General
saber rattling uh what do you feel about
what is happening
here I don't believe Iran wants a hot
war with the United States I believe
that Iran wants to to use people to kill
Israelis to kill Americans and see how
far it can go thus far it has been able
to go pretty far and there was a Great
Wall Street Journal editorial on this
that there is a sense that the American
president is much more interested in
avoiding conflict with Iran than in
fighting back against Iran so I I don't
predict a a a violent war with Iran
however it is accurate to say that there
is a World War now and there has been
for quite a while between the west and
those who hate the West Iran hates the
West the islamist world hates the West
not every Muslim the islamist world as
opposed to the Islamic world and the uh
people like Hamas hate the West Israel
is attacked for being an outpost of
Western civilization in the Middle East
it's fascinating that that is an attack
one would think that that would be
praise since Western Civilization has
been the most decent civilization ever
created in human history but it is used
as an attack by those who hate the West
the left not liberals the left and the
islamists and they are in alliance
against Israel and the United States all
right uh Jake yuger um I want to play a
clip from this interview between Douglas
Murray and Benjamin netan where he talks
about the war will take as long as it
takes let's watch
this we have to win in Gaza we have to
achieve total Victory Hamas cannot be
left standing coming out of the ruins
with a V sign and saying we'll do it
again again and again and again what I
say to our American friends whose help I
appreciate a great deal I said uh the
war will take as long as it takes but it
will result in total Victory because
this our battle is your battle and our
Victory is your Victory as well now Jake
I saw today that one of his cabinet was
suggesting that they believe
25% of Hamas terrorists have now been
killed and 25% more wounded wed and so
in their estimation 50% of the enemy has
now been effectively taken out of the
battlefield ad you think that is
probably true and B what do you make of
what Netanyahu said about this
effectively whether people like it or
not they're going to finish this
job yeah so I'll address the propaganda
first there's no way of confirming any
propaganda that comes out of Israel
those are madeup numbers but let's
assume for a second that it was true
okay so you've uh taken down half of
Hamas and killed 26,000 San people does
that mean are you're going to kill
another
26,000 how many Palestinians is America
supposed to help you murder for your
nonsense objective which never made any
sense in the first place which leads me
to the second part n yahu says two
absurd things uh one is an effort to
avoid accountability he keep kept saying
to Douglas over and over again oh in
terms of what went wrong on uh me not
defending Israel on October 7th when
they needed the defense not offense not
killing random innocent Palestinian
civilians but actual defense he says oh
we'll get to that accountability after
the war okay when is the war going to be
over he says well we have to have total
Victory what does that mean you have to
kill every member of Hamas well that
everybody knows that's impossible so oh
look at that he set up an impossible
standard for the war to be over so that
it's never over and we never get any
accountability and finally uh the idea
that America should fight Israel's war
for it is absurd no a hard no we should
send no money to Israel going forward to
kill innocent Palestinians or as long as
they do the occupation and now they're
dragging us into a giant war in the
Middle East that they're going to ask us
to pay for both in Blood and treasure
there's no Americans that are actually
in favor of that other than
neoconservatives that dragged us into
Iraq and that debacle over there so my
answer to Neto is a hard no no way do I
want to go to war with Iran to help your
political IAL career Dennis Prager do
you think Benjamin Netanyahu is long for
this world as the leader of Israel
because he's so on poopular domestically
the polls have never been worse for him
um you get a feeling of somebody where
the war is almost his last stand as
leader and in a very cynical way if he
stays in it long enough and can claim
victory over Hamas that might be his
only way of maintaining
power it's hard to imagine an other
Israeli leader acting
differently there is this perception in
the west and I'm neither a Netanyahu fan
nor a Netanyahu opponent but it is hard
to imagine an Israeli leader who would
say you know Kamas butchered our people
on October 7th raped our women burned
families alive want to destroy us want
to kill every Jew that they can find uh
but we won't respond militarily uh there
in in Israel there is virtual unanimity
there may be discussed with that man
individually I have no idea the British
kicked out Churchill after World War II
uh people are very fickle about their
about their political leaders so I have
no interest in what the polls are all I
can tell you is I can't think of an
Israeli leader who would be acting
differently yeah I think that's probably
true um J Yugo I want to talk about this
disturbing report which has come out
about the United Nations relief of Works
agency
where there were murmurings about
potential involvement of some of their
members in what happened um we've now
seen a Wall Street Journal investigation
which seemingly establishes uh from a
dossier actually the New York Times as
well an Israeli intelligence dossier uh
alleging that 200 workers uh from the UN
rwa are Hamas or Islamic Gad operatives
uh didn't provide detailed evidence the
dossy also alleged that 12 workers
crossed into Israel on October the 7th
with the Hamas terror group unrwa has
sacked nine of those employees and says
it's investigating another report by The
Wall Street Journal citing it also
Israeli intelligence dossier alleges
1,200 of the unrwa 12,000 employees in
Gaza have links to Hamas or Islamic
Jihad now I'm sure your first response
will be well I'm not going to believe
Israeli intelligence dossier but the
fact that the
unrwa has already sacked of these people
suggest there's a clear problem
there yeah so there's two different
issues here Pierce so uh first you're
right I don't believe Israeli propaganda
they say oh trust us there's hundreds of
them no I don't trust you at all uh the
IDF and the Israeli government have an
enormous track record of lying on almost
every occasion related to this war but
okay so you say there's nine folks
who've already been uh terminated and
that's fair and that's definitely true
so obviously there must be some evidence
okay great fantastic I want
accountability I don't want anybody
involved in the October 7th attacks and
they've been fired if you want to do a
further investigation to see if anybody
else was involved and you want to fire
them terrific no problem but that's not
the real issue here the real issue is uh
the right-wing Israeli government hates
this organization because they help
Palestinians there's now half a million
Palestinians that are starving and the
only people that are helping them is
basically this organization and Israel
thinks now their right-wing government
thinks well look if we can eliminate the
one organization that's helping
Palestinians they'll starve more that
way when we bomb them and we kill them
and we starve them there'll be no one to
help them so that'll help us with our
ethnic cleansing when we try to push
them into Egypt which several cabinet
ministers including their national
security minister have now said that is
what they want to do which is of course
ethnic cleansing 101 so they're
targeting this group to try to eliminate
its funding and it's working brilliantly
the Western Powers don't actually want
to help the Palestinians so they're
using this as an excuse to Target the
whole group and one last thing that
gives you a stark example of it let's
say that there was nine people or even a
couple hundred people inside Israel who
helped Hamas on October 7th it's not
impossible there could be collaborators
right so does that mean we should get
rid of funding for all of Israel it's an
absurd idea when you apply it to Israel
but somehow it's not absurd when you
apply to this organization from the
United Nations of course it's absurd
they should keep the funding but fire
anyone who was involved Dennis pry your
response to M St
well first let me just say the idea that
is Israel wants to starve the
Palestinians is vile it is it is another
left-wing atrocity on language like
Israel is committing
genocide genocide has been raped like
the word racism has been raped every
decent term has been denuded of its
meaning by people on the left not by
liberals I always draw that that
distinction but by people like Chen they
have raped the word genocide they have
raped the word racism they have raped
the word sexual attack all all the evils
have been removed from their context
Israel has no interest there are five
times more Palestinians today than there
were in 1950 it is the worst most
ineffective genocide in the history of
genocide it is a vile smear
the United Nations stinks the United
States should leave the United Nations
with every other
democracy it is a place where the Human
Rights Commission has been headed by
Iran where you have uh Iran even heading
the Women's Rights Commission it is a
terrible organization the United Nations
is to Nations what the university has
become to education it has become a
moral Cesspool it is time for America to
leave Jaye your response
finally yeah I mean this guy's hilarious
uh did he say I rape
words yes you rape words I I know you
find that funny it isn't funny yeah I do
yeah I think uh first of all that with
what you've done then by your own
definition is rape of the English
language and rape of the word rape uh
let alone the fact that uh of course you
know you say oh the left says racism
anytime anybody criticizes Israel what
do you guys all say anti seism have you
raped that word that's not true that's a
lie we say it about those who want to
destroy Israel not criticize Israel it
is a complete lie okay so let me address
the United Nations sure sure sure uh so
look the United Nations is all of the
Nations and right-wingers like Dennis
don't want want us to work with all the
nations they don't like peace they don't
like the world Community they say we're
the ones who write we're the good guys
and nyaho said this in the interview
that you uh display we're the good guys
they're the axes of evil and what is the
only answer for evil War so and that's
another thing that the United Nations is
trying to prevent war and so uh the
neoconservatives like Dennis Prager and
others go no no no no no United Nations
people working together we hate that a
people that have different opinions than
us we hate that people who are for peace
we hate that the only answer is war war
war war of course they don't like the
United Nations so what are we supposed
to do not have a United Nations we're
all just supposed to hate each other
forever never work together don't even
coordinate don't even communicate just
go to war forever and ever this is
insanity and by the way and the
occupation I'm the only candidate that
wants to end not the funding for Israel
not just to for this war but for the
occupation which is the core evil to use
the words of Dennis Prager and it is an
indisputable evil that Israel's doing
there and Israel doesn't have to do it I
believe Israel can be a great and
peaceful and flourishing country but
they must end the occupation Jank for
America
okay gentlemen I'm going to leave you
there thank you for a spirited debate I
appreciate it on satday next
controversial transgender swimmer Leah
Thomas has a sight some competing in the
women's category in the Olympics one of
her former teammates joins me
next we're here thanks for joining us
you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online on your smart speaker as well you
know what I love about toour today we do
it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any your will because
he delivered the referendum that he said
he would deliver the tor's love a scrap
you can almost see this coming around
the tracks with sella bravman she's
heading up one side and richy soon at
the other the police appr Pro Palestine
that is just not right you swearing off
in the police to act without fear or
favor the co inquiry seems to have
turned into a sort of pantomim there's
not really any substance to it's hard to
know whether it's a fce or a tragedy
there needs to be one human per machine
to come and rectify beats and the clanks
and when it goes wrong unexpected item
in bagging area I know are we only going
to be trusting sources like meta and
Google where is our unbi news going to
come from at Gram was president of the
Cambridge Union which is the rubbish
version of being president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass
for if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan you have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's about Twitter you sons of
can you please reinstate my account
thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this is
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling ring I've been answering
your question you answer mine it's
actually not my job to answer your
question are you prepared to call h a
terror is it possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth this is talk
TV
welcome back Leah Thomas Made Global
headlines when she became the first
transgender person to win a national
college title at swimming leading to
outrage from the women she defeated she
was ranked 65th when competing as a man
well three months after that win she was
banned from competing against biological
women but she's now maned a legal fight
to overturn the ban and has potentially
the Paris Olympics in her sight I'm
joined now by the former teammate o Leah
Thomas stand with spokeswoman Paula
scandan out kck's CEO Kay Travis and
political journalist and defender of the
indefensible on these things AA Santina
so welcome to all of you let me start
with you uh if I may Paula you have
competed against Leah Thomas in your
estimation how unfair is it that Leah
Thomas was allowed to compete against
biological females and is now trying to
seek legal address to do so but
potentially removing one woman from the
women's Olympic
team yeah it's incredibly unfair um I
think just looking at the situation Leah
Thomas was the tallest person on both
the men's and the women's team at the
University of Pennsylvania just the
height difference the muscle difference
the length in Bones the body shape um
and also the hormones that males have
that women don't that was obviously a
huge factor in Leah being much better
than the rest of us uh to put it into
perspective the University of
Pennsylvania has never had an NCAA
female champion ion until Leah Thomas
came around and I think that really
shows that our program went from hardly
ever having anyone qualify for the NCAA
Championship to having somebody win an
event and you you didn't actually
compete against her I think you competed
with her is that right yes I swam
different events than Leah but I was on
the same team right I mean I've just
seen you know some some of the video
clips from some of the races she was in
both when she competed as a man and then
as a woman and the difference is just
astounding I mean in One race she was
winning by over 50 seconds or something
crazy yeah and in that event actually
the second place finisher was a
University of Pennsylvania swimmer that
lost to Leah by over two laps in the
pool and if you were if you were a
member of the women's Olympic team for
the United States a woman and you lost
your place to Leah Thomas now how do you
think you'd
feel I would feel terrible and in fact
the girls that Leah beat when Leah won
the 500 yard freestyle
the second third and fourth place
finisher were Olympians themselves some
of which having medals so it already
happened and it would definitely happen
in the Olympics and I think that would
be a big Scandal because it would affect
not just NCAA athletes but all women
from all different countries that
compete in the sport of swimming and
also in other sports that they allow
this to happen in they will also be
affected as well right clay Travis I
I've got a feeling in like 10 years time
maybe sooner we're going to look back on
this period of of the existence of
planet Earth and think what the hell
were we doing how was this Insanity
being allowed to happen and it'll
probably culminate in a you know a 6' 6
in transgender athlete winning the 100
meters women's race at the Olympics by
about 50 yards I mean that's what's
going to
happen yeah I give credit to Paula uh
for speaking out and being willing to
point out how ridiculous this is because
I do think it's going to take take women
athletes uh more so than people like you
and me peers who can look at this and
talk about how ridiculous it is but what
we're starting to see is in America at
least uh when Gallup pulls this issue
increasingly massive majorities of the
American population are saying this is
wrong and Pierce I don't even think you
have to focus on sex itself uh obviously
men are bigger stronger and uh and
faster than women as a group and by the
way that doesn't mean that some women
aren't bigger stronger and faster than
some
men just on that point it is it is why
we separate the genders at the Olympics
I mean if you made gender if you had
what the there would never be you had
the woke dream of a gender neutral
Olympics can you imagine how many actual
women biological females would win a
medal I mean literally other than
probably equestrian and shooting maybe
that's
it yeah that's it that's it there would
be no women medalists that's why the the
separation occurs and by the way what I
focus on is I coach Little League Sports
I've got three boys if I showed up for
12-year-old soccer uh and I had a
16-year-old kid on my team every parent
would say no this is unacceptable you
can't do this can't do it for baseball
football basketball we have all sorts of
changes to regulations you can't be
trans AG right like I couldn't suddenly
decide that I'm going to be a little
leager that's why they asked for birth
certificates so you can go try to win
the Little League World Series because
otherwise would cheat you know and if I
suddenly said I'm coaching I'm about to
head as soon as I finish this interview
Pierce uh I'm going to go to seventh
grade basketball and watch my
13-year-old son uh participate if if
suddenly one of the coaches came out on
the court you know 6'4 and said hey I'm
trans AG now sure I'm 33 but I feel 13
everybody would think it was ridiculous
it's just the very essence of sport
itself yeah okay a I'm looking at you
frowning away here um explain to me why
this isn't just insane that Leah Thomas
who as we just heard was not just the
tallest boy in her College when she was
competing as a biological male but the
obviously the tallest girl as well how
can any of this be fair I think okay so
this is a really interesting topic for
someone who is gender critical because
on this show before we have discussed
puberty blockers and whether children
should be allowed access to them when
they are 12 13 years of age now boys
develop when they are 12 13 the that
they start to have testosterone that is
when they they they grow bigger they
have a larger muscle mass than women if
you don't want to see trans women
competing in women's sports then you're
going to have to allow young children
who do not feel who are experiencing
gender dysphoria to have those drugs
when they're younger no not at all you
are in my estimation you do one of two
things it's very straightforward this
whole supposed insolvable problem is
very straightforward trans women either
compete against other trans women in an
entirely new category as there are more
and more as there are more and more of
them competing or they compete against
their biological sex because that is the
biology they've been born with tell me
why that's not fair I don't think it's
fair that people who have experienced
gender dysphoria when they're growing up
and don't feel that they are in the
right body should not be allowed to
compete in sports and if you're going to
take away their rights why don't you
care look you you love you go on about
women's rights a lot of the time I agree
with you I want women to enjoy utter
fairness and equality I think how can
you possibly sign up to something that
is so grotesquely unfair and unequal
because Le to women's rights because Le
Thomas didn't wake up one morning and
suddenly decide I'm going to be able to
win in the women's category so I'm going
to that's exactly what she's doing
that's not that's not what happened
she's doing Le Thomas she is she is a
woman and so she is competing as a woman
she's a transwoman she is a woman she's
a transwoman we can go back and forth on
it she's a transwoman born with a
biological male body which gives her an
immediate massive advantage over women
who weren't so why aren't other members
of her team happy that they're finally
winning and qualifying for all of the
things that they never qualified for
before because they can all see that
it's un is it not a little bit of
jealousy no it's just they know that at
some stage Leah Thomas is going to
probably win the Olympic gold medal oh
no that would be awful for America that
would be terrible it would be here's
what it's terrible the United States
women's uh soccer team let's call it
soccer for the benefit of this
discussion because they call themselves
that well number one in the world the
best women soccer players on the planet
and they got beaten I think it was 8-1
by the Dallas under 15 boys team right
that is the point is that it wasn't that
the women's team weren't great as a
woman's team at soccer it's that put
them against a bunch of kids who are
male with male physiology they got
hammered okay that's why we separate the
Sexes so what do we say about trans
women then do we just say they're not
allowed to place for whatever are they I
just told you what we do they compete
against their biological sex which is
perfectly reasonable and fair that's not
reasonable it's perfectly reasonable by
the way solves the problem of the of the
dressing room too and who gets nak let's
talk about all of those years where they
would have been seeking medical
treatment and they weren't allowed
access to it now that's happening in the
UK and it's happening very much so in
the US people are being denied medical
treatment when they would like to have
it then when they get to of age you
don't let them play sports you and I are
going to come back to this when someone
like Le Thomas wins an Olympic gold
depriving a woman of winning Olympic
goals and you're going to finally say
peers you were right all along let's
take a short break I want to thank you
uh Paula we're going to let you go I
appreciate you joining us are going to
keep clay and AA for round two which is
a mixture of Taylor sft is she wrecking
American football as clay believes or
will she influence the election and the
Mona Lisa mob what do we do about these
idiots throw soup at them that's after
the
break we're here thanks for joining us
your with talk TV on TV on radio online
and we're on your smart
speaking criminals to useing XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten others no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn do you know
what I love about sport today we do it
all sunak sella
scon a woman can become a man and a man
can become a woman and if you think that
you're certifiably
insane slick Wishy seemed intelligent
forensic even a bit of a Statesman the
type of man you trust to look after your
house while you went on
holiday this concept that actually kids
wouldn't carry knives if they could go
and play Tiddly Winks at the you know
the corner of the street or whatever I
think it's a
nonsense happy THS night we slick it
cing timorous beasty of panics in
NY K ders accused the government of
failing a generation after a record
number of young people were killed last
year using a knif or sharp object we
need to make sure that when we say we're
going to ban them we actually do ban
them there are so many politicians now
who just say my that was the
boss you're David Cameron no he
wasn't was like brought to you by St KH
the mayor of London very rarely meet
anybody that says you know the thing
about London is it's got a great mayor
it's a deep calm brilliant
guy in the cities there are areas where
there are no vegetables it's
particularly difficult for those people
to do what Mark is saying if he comes up
with this argument again I'll sit on
it stop creating all of these funny
little factions with their funny little
names the new conservatives the ERG the
common sense research group the red wool
red trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what
what is that if you're talking about
multiculturalism it's workingclass white
boys who get put in the Army the poorest
people in society are the ones who are
going to be put on the front line
something is going horribly wrong we can
do a lot better Donald Trump didn't just
win he obliterated this is a guy facing
nearly a hundred criminal charges and
yet all all that's done is actually make
him more popular Trump is canny enough
to know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you or that's the way it comes I did my
6 months I came back nobody would touch
me I put my head down I persisted I
Carri on when I say I am God I'm not
joking did you feel Elvis was
controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a m in
power and are they terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that we're back C on senstive with my
pack AA and Clay tonight so clay let me
start with you because you're enraged by
the Taylor Swift phenomenon which from
what I'm looking at has made the NFL
massively more popular apparently TV
ratings are off the charts this season
for the NFL purely because of Taylor
Swift rocking up to see her boyfriend
Travis who won again last night and is
now in the Super Bowl it's the ultimate
American story isn't
it look I I I I have been to a Taylor
Swift concert I am not anti- Taylor
Swift Pier what most football fans
object to is the constant focus on
Taylor Swift now they've dialed it back
a bit she wasn't on the television that
much during the NFC champ AFC
Championship game uh between the Chiefs
and the Ravens and actually when CBS
showed her I don't know if you have the
clip Pierce it's kind of interesting she
was like take me off basically uh you
can see read her lips of her watching
watching herself on the screen so even
Taylor Swift herself seems to be
somewhat annoyed by the amount of
attention I do think it's been dialed
back lately here's the deal my my
football team real football Arsenal in
the Premier League over here haven't won
the league since 2004 20 years right if
we suddenly had Taylor Swift falling in
love with our Striker and it turned him
into a world beater and we won the
league I would be literally leading the
Swifty fank
I don't know what you're all moaning
about to be fair to be fair though Pier
Taylor uh Travis Kelce had a pretty
awful season when once this relationship
with public and she started attending
his games now he because of Patrick
Mahomes as his quarterback the greatest
quarterback uh in the NFL right now the
he did have a good game to be fair uh on
on yesterday uh but a lot of sports fans
don't want Taylor Swift taking over the
Super Bowl they want to get
and all here I think going to happen
she's going to fly back she's playing in
a concert in Japan she's just got time
apparently to get on a private playing
after get back in time she'll attend
Kansas City Chiefs San Francisco 4
nights uh the Chiefs will win uh her
boyfriend will be the man of the match
and score the winning touchdown ratings
will smash all records and it will be
another Accolade for the great Taylor
let's turn it on to Mona Lisa though go
49ers save us I'm in the old Chiefs camp
um am I not allowed to say much I love
Taylor's yeah I know you love her so you
said you said that you love of course
you nothing about football you just love
seeing Taylor I want to talk about Mona
Lisa very quickly these idiots who who
invaded the Louver in Paris I was in
Paris at the weekend this is all
happening and threw uh it turned out to
be pumpkin soup over the pain obviously
didn't actually hit the exact canvas
because it's protected and so on but
once again AA what did they hope to
achieve apparently they were protesting
to raise awareness about hunger in
France they just wasted buckets of soup
that could have fed hungry people okay I
think this is a fantastic protest and
you've got to say one thing the French
do really well is protest okay over here
you don't see half what you see in
France you don't see the Streets On Fire
you don't see soup thrown at the Monita
and look I have to say everyone was
being a bit wet in their reaction to
this it's got a glass screen on it the
painting isn't damaged and they've made
headline news around the world and you
think that wasting buckets of soup is
the best way to highlight hunger do you
really think that those couple of cans
of soup would have sold world hunger why
don't you say that in places which have
abject poverty and real hunger oh come
on see how far a couple of buckets soup
would take this has done more to raise
awareness of nobody knows what they were
doing raising awareness for only I do
because I researched the group
thankfully you've told us now so now we
all know and they're related to just up
Bo distinction from Rebellion they're
all part of the same collaboration and
it's like just nothing they do ever
makes anybody want to join their call I
don't agree I don't agree with that
because the group has expanded
significantly and look the best way to
go go about protest is direct action
we're at a point in time where
politicians are not listening well stop
wrecking everybody's fun stop trashing
paintings particularly stop going after
Cricket pitches grow up protest properly
democratically uh clay got to leave it
there great to have you go the Chiefs uh
and stop the moaning leases that's it
from me whatever you're up to keep it on
sens good
[Music]
night
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costumes
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well trained most dog owners will tell
you a dog can turn you know what I love
about talk today we do it all sunak so
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
on to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had boost Rockets attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what rashak has done the question now
is what he does next the police are pro
Palestine that is just not right you
swear an o in the police to act without
fear or favor the co inquiry seems to
have turned into a sort of pantomim
there's not really any substance to it
it's hard to know whether it's a fce or
a tragedy talk TV has spoken exclusively
to a member of the Blade Runners do you
have a message for sadique Khan we're
not stopping until you stop the amount
of time it's taken the number of illegal
migrants currently sent by us to Rwanda
zil the amount of money it's cost we're
saying what are we saying it's cost
about 140 million 140 million P so far
so40 million so far result nil
absolutely nil are we only going to be
trusting sources like meta and Google
where is our unbiased news going to come
from K in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his fat ass
talking for a liit if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan she have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC Mouse man MC mous
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got a house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film